THERE IS A VACCINE, BUT NO CURE.
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THE PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT.
ALL OVER TELEVISION, YOU ARE
WATCHING PEOPLE DOWNPLAY CHINA’S
ROLE IN SPREADING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
DOWNPLAYING IT.
ON CNN, THAT’S NOT ENOUGH.
THEY ALWAYS GO THE EXTRA STEP
OVER THERE.
SOME CNN CONTRIBUTORS HAVE
PRACTICALLY BECOME EMISSARIES
FOR BEIJING.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT WAS CHINA THAT CAME TO THE
RESCUE, SENDING MEDICAL
PERSONNEL AMONG NINE PALLETS OF
VENTILATORS, ELECTROCARDIOGRAPH,
AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MASKS,
ALL DESPERATELY NEEDED BY A
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN CRISIS AND
APPRECIATED BY ITALIANS SINGING
CHINA’S PRAISES.
EUROPE HAD FEWER OPTIONS.
A GRADUAL WORSENING OF THE
TRANSATLANTIC ALLIANCE.
MOST RECENTLY, OVER TRUMP’S
FAILURE TO CONSULT EUROPE OVER
THE CORONAVIRUS TRAVEL BAN.
CHINA, NOW STEPPING INTO THE
GLOBAL LEADERSHIP RULE, LONG
ABANDONED BY THE AMERICAN
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: IT’S ALMOST
UNBELIEVABLE THAT THEY RAN THAT
ON THE AIR.
SLACKING FOR THE COMMUNIST